oh
an eel wind blows from beyond the
horizon
a new danger is coming on the tides
and the one who might stop this ruin
trot for all forever in the sea of the
damned
now to save the pirate life
you must start by saving the life of
one
oh didn't realize we had company
captain jack sparrow
but i suspect you already knew that
because of the treasure jack storm a
darkness
followed in here and if it's not stopped
this world will sink into shadow
this sea holds many secrets
ah a new body of lies all i can do is
sure you know here
from what i hear of this so-called sea
of thieves
is nothing but curse crews blood versus
mermaids a legion of dead
angry pirates oh yes
and now one davy jones
[Applause]
well i believe that now is the perfect
time to use these
cannons
a world without the eternal face
is a world that refuses to face the
truth
nothing lasts forever destroy that
i don't suppose by chance there's a
second one of those
the sea of thieves i bring me that
horizon
play it with xbox game pass